what's going on how are you i sat next
to you at the razzle Skywalker premiere
I got four jokes in that movie I'm very
proud I love that movie which jokes were
yours
I'm little punching up with c-3po for
that film okay I tiny I got like four
little poor little ha ha Jin there it
was a big big see droopy Oh movie thank
you so much thank you so much I had
almost nothing to do with that movie did
you I did yeah because I helped out with
bb-8 nine seven and then I got one joke
in seven so now I got it up to four in
this one I love that because when I
watched EFA I was like yeah why is he
what is he even doing those premiers are
so crazy because they closed down all of
Hollywood and every theater is Star Wars
it's I don't know another movie that
could do anything like that I'm Sonic a
little ball of super energy in an
extremely handsome package you are
freakin Sonic I am and that crazy crazy
I am this version of Sonic it's blowing
my mind yeah look I know you were
mentioned this earlier the Easter eggs
are like my favorite part of them oh did
you play the video game stuff growing up
oh yeah there's a part where they're
like painting and it's like playing
they're like green hill zone yeah of the
Easter Egg yeah there's a couple well I
also put Easter eggs up myself in that
not me but I did a to Jim Carrey
impressions in it one is there there's a
fish on my head and I say it in the same
way that he goes our pets heads are
falling off from dumb and dumber and
there's one more that's gonna be an
easter egg when you watch because there
hasn't been clip yet but there's a great
one where in the original sonic can
become close to the edge he kind of goes
like this it's in the hotel room Jeff
and Tyson all those guys put that in
there as well which is amazing in Sonic
2 whenever I have to like when you like
release all the animals that was like
the one thing I would do I would wait
the best when you're on that little
Oakland you actually did better yeah
when you're on that thing yeah that's
like anytime you're playing those games
like Castlevania before the orbit goes
you try jumping catch it so it doesn't
hit the ground yeah yeah yeah on same
level okay now I got to know your coach
your co-star Adam pally this punches
baby Yoda in the mandible
and I'm just curious how you feel about
me I feel like I'm so proud of Adam he's
in this movie too I know that it makes
me so happy the fact that he got to be a
stormtrooper and punch a child version
of Yoda yeah I feel like was Adam
pallies dream he's been skipping all the
carpets because he doesn't know because
Yoda is around and he's like afraid that
baby odors gonna jump out of some sort
of red camera if you will and really
take him everything well ok sonic went
through this major redesign like we saw
his big muscular thighs and ever almost
like and then we saw another version or
never was like food and now he's like
full sonic daddy the way we knew him and
you're calling him FSD full Sonic Daddy
Sonic dad ok yeah keep going so how do
you feel how did you feel about the
whole redesign the biggest thing for us
is so we filmed this entire movie right
and I was doing vo for it at that time
and we had no idea if anybody would care
it's an entity that I really loved and
Jeff and all these guys really care
about so the trailer that first trailer
for us was okay we'll see if anybody
cares and then the passion from the fans
and how much people cared and how much
they were invested in the character was
enormous for us because like oh we have
something special here we have a
character people care about and we
really like the story we're telling so
the biggest thing from that is like oh
people care we can if we play this
correctly you know what I mean we're
really excited to bring this to the
screen and make them look beautiful and
all that self yeah well I can't not ask
about Jim Carrey yes he was right there
he is like dr. Robotnik and Robotnik
he's Eggman right now what was it like I
mean seeing him go just pull Jim Carrey
in this movie I know you don't really
have scenes with him you're very kind to
know that for me it was I get to watch
the movie for everybody else because I'm
doing a lot of Sonic stuff and I
remember we were watching it and Jeff is
showing me the film and I made him stop
I was like oh my goodness he's like he
is doing he's Jim Carrey he's like he's
so funny in it and he you realized that
he's just taking move his hand and he
can make you laugh he has a skill set
that other human beings just don't have
and so he does it in this movie I feel
like we just got lucky that he's like
you know what I'm gonna do for this
movie I'm just gonna be the funniest
person the universe yeah and he's
incredible in it it's so exciting to
watch
[Music]